imagine standing at the origin of a
number line and placing little identical
lighthouses on all of the positive
integers you know 1 2 3 4 and so on what
is the intensity of the light that you
see well if you rescale units so that
the brightness from that first light is
one say measured as the energy your eye
is receiving from it per unit time then
by the inverse Square law the brightness
of that second Lighthouse would be 1/4
the brightness of the third would be 1
nth and so on and so forth which means
means the total brightness from all of
them together is 1 plus a 4th plus a 9th
adding on all of the reciprocals of the
square numbers up to Infinity this value
turns out to be very special it is
precisely pi^ 2 / 6 I know it's amazing
why is pi there and why would you square
it this game with the lighthouses is
more than just a cute way to visualize
the sum it's the beginning of a very
clever proof by Yan wund that explains
why this sum is related to
circles